[Musik]
jänner 2009 10
österreich kämpft gegen schneemassen in
spitzenzeiten unterstützt von rund 1.700
soldatinnen und soldaten des
österreichischen bundesheers
850 eingeschneite personen können
mittels hubschrauber in sicherheit
gebracht werden
mehr als zehn tonnen lebensmittel und
medikamente werden kanzelte
transportiert
[Musik]
für die eingesetzten kräfte hat
verteidigungsminister mario kunasek
entsprechende dienstfreistellungen
angeordnet als wertschätzung für die
erbrachte leistung so kunasek innen
außen
[Musik]
danke für den unermüdlichen einsatz ist
auch aus der betroffenen bevölkerung
gekommen
in der steiermark bedankt sich ein
betroffener mittels schnee botschaft
basierte pcs bundesheer immerhin setzt
für ganz normal ist also tief ins für
mich persönlich finde es nicht normal
wenn kinder schon vor seiner regierung
darauf ist eine einladung in den
fliegerhorst aigen im ennstal gefolgt
teilnahme an einem trainingsflug
inklusive trainer sorgen dass gerade
[Musik]
ebenfalls im jänner 2009 10 findet ein
verteidigungsminister treffen statt die
minister aus der schweiz deutschland und
österreich treffen in wien zu gesprächen
zusammen
damals noch als deutsche
verteidigungsministerium in wien die
jetzige eu ratspräsidentin ursula von
der leyen und europa wenn ich das hier
sagen darf braucht die gesamte
gestaltungskraft österreichs denn
österreich und ich sage das mit allem
respekt vor der neutralität ihres landes
gehört zu denen die genau wissen dass in
der heutigen welt sicherheit nur
gemeinsam zu erreichen ist im februar
2009 10 wird bei den pionieren in
salzburg und bei der dritten
jägerbrigade in niederösterreich
aufgerüstet die einsatz wichtigen
transportfahrzeuge regelungs und dingo 2
a 3 werden in den dienst gestellt für
uns ist natürlich auch heute ein
besonderer tag für die salzburger
pioniere in der sechste gepäcks brigade
da wir heute gerät bekommen haben das
für uns einsatz wichtig ist und für
unsere füllung unsere aufgabe uns einen
weiteren schritt nach vorne bringt ich
glaube dass dieses gerät ein meilenstein
auch ist der weiterentwicklung nach des
bundesheeres einer von vielen schritten
die wir noch brauchen
[Musik]
ebenfalls im februar findet in tirol die
weltmeisterschaft der gebirgs soldaten
die edelweiß radstadt soldatinnen und
soldaten aus zwölf nationen zeigen dabei
ihr können empfinden und bergung
verschütteter personen militärische
aufklärung und abzeichen jährige in
vielem mehr
dieser welt kommt zeigt den extrem hohen
ausbildungsstand nicht nur der
österreicher sondern auch der anderen
teams
[Musik]
märz wird in wien der protektion preis
des österreichischen bundesheers
verlinkt dabei outet sich der
preisträger dompfarrer toni faber als
glühender unterstützer des bundes ärzte
es hat so ausgesehen in den letzten
eineinhalb jahren dass es bergauf geht
aber es sind noch viele anstrengungen
notwendig dass das bundesheer wirklich
seine verfassungsmäßigen gebundenen
aufgaben erfüllen kann und ich bete
nicht nur für sondern setze mich dort
unter einem politischen gesprächen noch
dafür ein
[Musik]
anfang april findet auch 2009 10 wieder
die harris flugretter ausbildung statt
in aigen im ennstal werden
verschiedenste szenarien intensiv
trainiert zu den aufgaben des heeres von
krebszellen das bergen von verletzten
oder verwundeten soldaten aus
schwierigen gelände lufttransport bergen
von mehreren personen im rahmen einer
hochwasserkatastrophe also diese massen
immer kirchen videos bezeichnen
zusammenfassend ein spezialist in der
zusammenarbeit
im mai entsendet österreich soldatinnen
und soldaten zu ibm die european junior
training mission im afrikanischen mali
privateer christian habersatter
übernimmt für sechs monate das kommando
der eu mission also eine der
wesentlichen herausforderungen im mal
ist die entwicklung der sicherheitslage
wie sie das wahrscheinlich auch verfolgt
haben hat sich die nicht verbesserte
gegenteil sogar etwas verschlechtert
[Musik]
2009/10 betriebsbereich politisches
neuland erstmals in der geschichte der
zweiten republik wird im parlament einer
amtierenden bundesregierung das
misstrauen ausgesprochen
der bundespräsident ernennt eine aus
experten bestehende übergangsregierung
im verteidigungsressort folgt auf mario
kunasek zunächst kurzzeit minister
johann luif der wenige tage später von
thomas starlinger als
verteidigungsminister abgelöst wird
ich glaube dass sich die verfassung und
alle gesetze der republik getreulich
beobachten und meine pflicht nach besten
wissen und gewissen erfüllen werde
[Musik]
das große militärmusikfestival findet im
juni in oberösterreich statt alle neuen
österreichischen militär musiken und 450
musikerinnen und musiker kommen zu einem
mehr als zweistündigen konzert zusammen
in der bis auf den letzten platz restlos
ausverkauften tips arena in linz
[Musik]
im juli 2009 10 findet in tirol eine
groß angelegte milizübungen stadt
ausgangslage ist dass diese über ein
sehr realistisches szenario
zum inhalt hat nämlich den schutz
kritischer infrastrukturen also europa
und weltweit ein aktuelles thema ist
[Musik]
bei der übung scheitelhöhe 19 steht der
schutz sensibler infrastruktur
insbesondere der durch tirol laufenden
transalpinen ölpipeline kurz zahl
genannt im mittelpunkt bis jetzt bin ich
mit dem übungslauf sehr zufrieden wir
haben ganz viel erfahrungen sammeln
können ganz viel lernen können
[Musik]
im salzburger rußbach wüten im juli
unwetter die teile der landesstraße b
166 unterspülen und damit die
hauptverbindung zwischen abtenau und
rußbach unterbrechen
über 60 pioniere des bundesheeres rücken
haus am innerhalb weniger tage eine
behelfsbrücke zu errichten um die
wichtige verbindung für die menschen in
der region wieder herzustellen
[Musik]
2009/10 feiert das amt für rüstung und
wehrtechnik kurz ard genannt sein
150-jähriges bestehen dass rwe prüft und
testet nahezu alles was beim
österreichischen bundesheer zum einsatz
kommt von uniform stoff über alle
unterschiedlichen waffengattungen von
robotik bis hin zur simulations- und
ausbildungs anlagentechnik
[Musik]
im september findet im steirischen
zeltweg österreichs größte airshow die
airpower statt
[Musik]
fast 200 flugzeuge und helikopter zeigen
an zwei veranstaltungstagen ihre einsatz
leistung rund 185.000 besucherinnen und
besucher sind begeistert von den
vorführungen nationaler und
internationaler flug staffel
[Musik]
ende september beenden 30
berufsoffiziere und 45 milito feeds ihre
erfolgreich ihre militärische ausbildung
mit einem festakt auf dem maria
theresienplatz der militärakademie in
wiener neustadt werden sie von
bundespräsident alexander van der bellen
verteidigungsminister thomas steininger
und generalstabschef robert bringt
offiziell in das bundesheer übernommen
ist das wirklich einzuschätzen heute in
vechta kompakt das ende des vertrags um
seine folgen 2009/10 setzt brigadier
walter feichtinger seine analysen
komplexe themen in seiner serie
feichtinger kompakt fort seit mehr als
zwei jahren analysiert der
militärstratege des österreichischen
bundesheeres konflikte auf der ganzen
welt und erklärt sachlich und kompetent
die hintergründe 2009 10 wird die
produktion der fünfzigste ausgabe von
wer kontakt gewalt
anfang oktober findet den steirischen
fürstenfeld die kt sicherheitskonferenz
statt und 2.000 teilnehmerinnen höheren
verschiedenste vorträge zum thema
it-sicherheit
ein hauptthema unter experten die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines black out also
eines großflächigen stromausfalls ist
größer als je zuvor
weil ich beschäftige mich seit dem jahr
2011 mit diesem thema und wie die
entwicklung der letzten acht angelaufen
sind und dass das in den nächsten fünf
jahren auf europäischer ebene geplant
ist die ich fix davon aus dass wir in
dieser zeit dieses eigenes erleben
werden die leistungsschau des
österreichischen bundesheeres
nationalfeiertag im oktober 2019 fällt
zu klein aus wie nie zuvor
grund dafür ist die äußerst angespannte
finanzielle lage das bundesheer stehe
finanziell mit dem rücken zur wand so
ein sprecher des
verteidigungsministeriums
verteidigungsminister thomas stallinger
ortet allerdings immer größer werdenden
zuspruch in der bevölkerung die eine
erhöhung des jahresbudgets positiv
gegenüber stehen dialog mit der
bevölkerung ist mir sehr wichtig vor
allem war das ein grund warum uns
entschieden haben trotz der sparzwänge
diesen nationalfeiertag in der arbeit
durchzuführen
wir haben einen juni schon eine
meinungsumfrage kauft muss sich über 60
prozent der österreicherinnen und
österreicher gesagt dass unser bargeld
in der zwischenzeit sind es über 80 und
wenn überzeugt nach dem heutigen tag
wird es noch ein paar prozentpunkte mehr
sein
[Musik]
im november findet die größte übung des
bundesheeres 2019 statt in ober und
niederösterreich insbesondere auf dem
truppenübungsplatz einsteigt trainieren
2300 soldatinnen soldaten aus österreich
deutschland und kroatien die
zusammenarbeit im zuge einer
stabilisierungs operation im rahmen
eines einsatzes der eu battlegroup wir
üben hier gerade mit internationaler
beteiligung spricht mit soldaten aus
deutschland aber auch aus kroatien hier
eine gemeinsame übung damit diese
versorgungseinheit in dieser eu
battlegroup dementsprechend auch
vorbereitet sein kann weil nächstes jahr
im märz gibt es die internationale
zertifizierung in deutschland und auf
dahin bereiten wir uns vor und
trainieren wir hin
[Musik]
im dezember 2009 10 besuchen
verteidigungsminister thomas steininger
und generalstabschef robert brieger das
österreichische kfor kontingent im
kosovo und das heu vor kontingent in
sarajevo in bosnien und herzegowina
während dem kosovo aus völlig
weihnachten gefeiert wird steht in
bosnien und herzegowina zusätzlich ein
großes jubiläum an
seit 2004 läuft unter dem namen oil for
die friedensmission der europäischen
union zur einhaltung des dayton
abkommens seit 15 jahren mit der
beteiligung von soldatinnen und soldaten
aus österreich
ich möchte mich bei allen soldatinnen
und soldaten des österreichischen
bundesheeres für ihre einsatz leistungen
im in und ausland herzlich bedanken
sie leisten wesentliche beiträge für die
sicherheit österreichs und darüber
hinaus für sicherheit und stabilität in
den regionen und international
ich bekam den kosovo beim
österreichischen kontigent bei der vor
einer feier und wünsche allen
soldatinnen und soldaten
ein frohes weihnachtsfest an guten
rutsch auf den angehörigen alles gute zu
hause und dass alle wieder gesund von
den einsätzen nach hause zurückkehren